le centre-ville de valentigney désert en
ce samedi après midi
mairie fermée rideaux des commerces
baisser
une opération ville morte pour soutenir
les salariés de peugeot japy menacés de
licenciement plus de 300 personnes ont
défilé dans les rues de valentigney
claude françois sommier habite ici
depuis plus de 20 ans elle tenait à être
là on peut pas accepter qu'une usine
sont embarqués dans des méandres de
rachat avec une perte devriez aussi
important contre la casse sociale
moi je suis du quartier de sous roche du
quartier où il yal usine où il ya
beaucoup de gens qui travaillent donc il
me semble très important d'être présent
cet après midi une vingtaine d'élus a
également marcher aux côtés des salariés
le maire de valentigney s'inquiètent des
conséquences d'éventuelles suppressions
de postes sur son territoire d'ailleurs
chaque emploi c'est une famille qui a
derrière et c'est tout le pays de
montbéliard
c'est mon territoire qui risque d'être
impacté 14 pays de montbéliard donc je
peux pas laisser faire ça c'est pas
possible
vous avez aujourd'hui des gens qui sont
motivés pour travailler dans ses
cuisines il ya un savoir faire qui est
connu ça fait plus de cent ans qu'elle
existe
donc voila moi ce que je veux c'est
préserver un maximum l'emploi les
salariés de peugeot j'appliquerai note
aussi la remise en cause de leurs acquis
sociaux
en fait on travaillera 40 heures pays 37
à la fin de l'année quand on calcule ça
nous ferait en gros 32 jours taille
gratuitement à la grâce du patron
le sort de l'entreprise sera scellé le
15 mars prochain
deux projets de reprise du sous traitant
automobile doivent être examinées par le
tribunal de commerce de grenoble